faites vous confiance aux inconnus votre
mère vous a toujours dit de ne pas faire
ça elle a raison les amis aujourd'hui à
faire une vidéo qui a pas spécialement
être rigolo mais qui me tient à coeur
il ya plein de trucs que j'aime bien
dans la vie heureusement sinon je me
fais chier et l'une de ces choses et la
sociologie étudier les comportements
humains et les faits sociaux c'est
passionnant je trouve je suis tombé sur
un jeu qui s'appelle the evolution of
creux l'évolution de la confiance et je
trouve que c'est hyper intéressant parce
que aujourd'hui dans une société où il
ya plus en plus d'égoïsme enfin c'est la
pensée générale on est tous un peu
méfiants les uns les autres même si des
fois ya pas trop de raison de l'être
enfin voilà ce jeu a été créé par un mec
qui nous montre pourquoi les choses sont
devenues comme ça c'est parti playes
pendant la première guerre mondiale
c'était la fin de la paix il s'est passé
un truc assez remarquable le noël 1914
sur le front à je pense que vous vous
connaissez cette histoire moi je connais
en dépit de l'interdiction formelle de
sympathiser avec l'ennemi les soldats
anglais et allemands ont quitté leurs
tranchées ont traversé la no man's land
dont kano madeleine c'est la zone entre
les deux tranchées où il ya les des
échanges de balles quoi donc si un
michael haigh des scènes immédiatement
ils se sont rassemblées pour enterrer
leurs morts s'échanger des cadeaux et
jouer à des jeux en plein temps de
guerre vous imaginez pendant ce temps là
nous sommes en 2017 ça fait des
décennies que l'occident est en période
de paix non n'a jamais été aussi
méfiants les sondages montrent que sur
ces 40 dernières années les gens
demandent de plus en plus donc voici
notre énigme pourquoi en temps de paix
les amis deviennent des ennemis et
pourquoi en temps de guerre les ennemis
deviennent des amis trop ce genre de
truc j'espère réussir dans cette vidéo à
vous faire aimer ça parce que
franchement il ya de quoi être hub à toi
d'un objectif je pense que la théorie
des jeux peut expliquer d'autres
épidémies de la méfiance et comment on
peut arranger ça pour comprendre tout ça
joue un jeu voilà c'est marty le jeu de
la confiance au caire qu'il a il a fait
un petit jeu pour qu'on comprenne mieux
ce délire de la méfiance et de la
confiance tu as un choix en face de toi
ya une machine si tu mets une pièce dans
la machine l'autre joueur va recevoir
trois pièces et vice versa si lui aussi
met une pièce tu vaut aussi en recevoir
3 vous pouvez tous les deux choisir de
coopérer donc mettre une pièce ou de
tricher ne pas mettre de pièces imagine
que l'autre joueur triche est nommé pas
de pièce qu'est ce que tu vas faire
moi je vais coopérer plus d'insultés sur
sa page facebook donc c'est un gros
lâche c'est faux si on est certains
qu'ils trichent
on va tricher aussi on va dire qu'on a
le droit c'est logique qu'ils aient
d'accord
exactement pourquoi tu le laisses rétaux
berné situe coopèrent et qu'ils trichent
tu vas perdre une pièce pendant que lui
va en gagner trois ajustée toutefois si
vous trichez tous les deux bah aucun de
vos va gagner ou perdre quoi que ce soit
score 0 0
morales t'as intérêt à tricher c'est
l'autriche ok maintenant disons que
l'autre joueur coopèrent et qui met une
pièce qu'est ce que tu vas faire tu va
coopérer jusque là tout est parfaitement
logique et c'est ce qu'on ferait tous
bien sûr ça a l'air d'être le choix le
plus juste à moins que ça ne soit pas si
vous coopérez tous les deux vous
dépensez chakan ps pour en gagner trois
mais si tu triches alors qu'ils
coopèrent tu vas gagner trois pièces et
lui il en aura perdu une donc tu devrais
toujours triché et voici donc un tri
dilemna confiance c'est bien mais ça
permet aux autres de prendre un avantage
sur toi où ça leur permet de tirer
dessus quand tu sors non armé d'une
tranchée comme mon noël 1914 parfois la
méfiance est rationnel maintenant voyons
ce qui se passe quand on joue à ce jeu
plusieurs fois aux jeunes trop c'est
trop violent
jusque là ils ont raison c'est la vérité
maintenant jouons pour de vrai tu vas
jouer contre cinq adversaires différents
chacun avec sa propre stratégie avec
chaque opposant tu vas jouer entre trois
et sept fois d'affilée et tu ne seras
pas en avance quelles routes des lots
dernier battu leur faire confiance
ou alors peuvent-ils te faire confiance
à la lata hockey mise en pratique de ce
qu'il vient de dire on est contre un
inconnu on sait pas ce qui va faire ou
comment socheat on coopère moi j'aurais
tendance à coopérer au début je passe un
fils de plus dans le doute jusqu'au père
ok il a coopéré aussi on est bien j'ai
coopéré lac opéré il ya aucune raison de
se mettre à tricher maintenant alors on
recopie rire coopèrent aussi c'est
parfait on va récupérer
hirko perd aussi c'est parfait ok fin du
premier cas de figure le mec en face au
père et à chaque fois je coopérer à
chaque fois tout s'est bien passé hockey
nouvel adversaire jusqu'au opèrent au le
fils de on va tricher palmata arrêté
josy on va tricher ils trichent aussi
voilà il en des courses on a perdu une
pièce si on a gagné trois nouvelles
personnes on va coopérer tout se passe
bien
[Musique]
et là on aurait tendance à se dire
la partie d'avant je me suis fait
pourquoi moi je n'écris pas cette
personne à son tour pour récupérer ce
que j'ai perdu donc on va tricher aux
lapins souris
ok nouveau perso on va tricher
maintenant on va coopérer
ok il nous a berné on a donc gagné 2
puis à chacun on arrête les conneries
onco permanent au qe2 il fait que
tricher c'est un bâtard c'est un bâtard
alors ton score et le 31 le score le
plus bas c'est 7 et le plus haut c 49
donc qui étaient ces étranges
personnages contre qui tu viens de jouer
d'accord donc il fait une liste des cinq
personnalités possible donc vous allez
sûrement vous reconnaître parmi l'une de
ces cinq personnalités premiers
caractères possible l'imitateur c'est
celui qui commence et en coopérant et
qui ensuite copier tout ce que je
faisais tu avais celui qui faisait que
de tricher j'espère que personne n'a
reconnu à celle qui faisait que de
coopérer catherine caractère celui qui
grognent c'est celui qui commençait par
coopérer et si je trichais une fois
contre lui il trichait surtout les
routes qui suivait et le dernier si le
détective il va m'analyser va commencer
par coopérer ensuite il va tchité une
fois et ensuite il va coopérer deux fois
ci un pressage triche une fois il va se
mettre à faire comme le mec qui copie si
je triche pas il va faire comme celui
qui triche tout le temps pour
m'exploiter alors qu elle maintenant
voyons si chacun ses caractères jouer
les uns contre les autres c'est
intéressant on va mettre du coup tous
les profils l'un contre l'autre c'est un
tournoi chaque perso va maintenant jouer
contre l'autre ça fait un total de dix
matches et dix rounds par match
ok c'est le moment les pronostics selon
vous quel caractère va obtenir le plus
de pièces celui qui coopèrent tout le
temps il va forcément un perdant parce
qu'en face quand ça va tricher lui va
continuer de coopérer te comprend celui
qui fait que trichet
bah ça va marcher que au premier round
et les neuf rounds a prévu la personne
en face va tricher aussi parce qu'elle a
bien comprendre que ça fdp donc ça va
être entre le grunge heures et le
détective et le grunge heures je
rappelle celui qui va commencer en
coopérant et qui va continuer de
coopérer tant que je coopère raconte dès
que je vais tchité il va acheter jusqu'à
la fin des iem je pense que c'est le
détective à ce qu'au final il va
exploiter la personne faible vous avez
vu j'ai dit la personne faible alors que
c'est ou en disant ça je pense à la
personne qui va faire que de coopérer
mais l'epa faible elle est juste
bienveillante donc il va exploiter la
personne bienveillante et il va savoir
contrer la personne malveillante donc
c'est forcément détective pour moi qui
va gagner ok maintenant voyons les
matches un par un et voyons comment ça
se passe
premier match l'imitateur conduit qui
trichent tout le temps et bat
l'imitateur savoir au premier round mais
à tous les rounds après il s'est plu à
voir deuxième round
l'imitateur compte celui qui fait que de
coopérer eh ben ils gagnent tous les
deux un troisième round
l'imitateur contre celui qui grognent
ils gagnent tous les deux 20 aussi
quatrième round l'imitateur qu'on le
détective l'imitateur va tricher une
fois quand le détective va tricher lors
du deuxième round bilan ils gagnent
chacun 18 pièces cinquième match celui
qui triche contre celui qui coopèrent
tout le temps celui qui triche ressort
gagnant de 30 pièces en est ce qu'ils
coopèrent tout le temps il en a perdu 10
c'est triste celui qui coopèrent tout le
temps contre le détective et là il se
fait manger parce que le détective
comprends qu'il ait trop de bonne foi et
va l'arnaqué encore et encore du coup
celui qui coopèrent perd 1 et le
détective gagne 27 fdp
bref je vous épargne tout ça c'est un
peu long or c'est celui qui copie tout
le temps qui ressort le plus gagnant de
tout ça donc
l'imitateur passe par de nombreux non la
règle d'or l'altruisme réciproque
ou encore vivre et laisser vivre c'est
pour ça que la paix est apparu ce soir
de noël dans les tranchées de la
première guerre mondiale quand vous êtes
force à jouer le même jeu avec les mêmes
personnes spécifiques encore et encore
et pas avec l'ennemi générique emma
l'imitateur ne gagne pas juste la
bataille
il gagne la guerre mais si les choses
changent quand tu joues encore et encore
au même jeu voyons voir ce qui se passe
quand on joue plusieurs tournois olala
ça part en steaks
oh c'est indécent maintenant
laissons notre population de joie
évoluer à travers le temps c'est une
danse en trois temps premièrement au
jour un tournoi
laissons-les tout jouer les uns contre
les autres et quand on leur score de on
élimine les losers on dégage les 5 plus
mauvais joueur s'il ya une égalité
choisi au pif entre tristesse trois ont
reproduit les gagnants ont clown les
cinq meilleurs joueurs et on refait sa
autant qu'on le voudra donc à chaque
fois on va faire un tournoi on va
éliminer les 5 plus mauvais et on va
cloner les cinq meilleurs à la fin il
n'en restera car qu'une seule catégorie
de personnes voyons ça en actions disons
qu'on commence avec une population de 25
personnes armées elles y en a 15 qui
font que de coopérer 5 qui font que
tricher et cinq qui sont des imitateurs
je pense c'est ce qu'ils coopèrent tout
le temps qu'ils vont dégager forcément
mais celui qui triche tout le temps
c'est évident qu'ils gagnent quand lui
qui coopèrent tout le temps mes skis
guingamp celui qui mitent à je sais pas
bon voyons la réponse c'est quoi
du coup on se retrouve à exit tricheurs
dix personnes qui coopèrent tout le
temps et 5 imitateur maintenant qu'est
ce qui se passe qu'on refait un tournoi
au hockey eh ben je crois que c'est
exactement pareil on élimine les cinq
pistes et le caractère qui coopèrent
tout le temps et on reproduit le 5
meilleurs c'est ceux qui trichent tout
le temps ouais mais quoi ils vont se
retrouver entre eux ils vont être baiser
et vont regagner 000 ans à l'histoire
ben voilà exactement c'est ce qui
commence à se passer là ils ont gagné
165 piège chacun sait autant que les
imitateurs alors celui qui coopèrent
soutenu à gagner que 30 au reproduisons
5 du top 5
et ça nous donne 6 imitateur pour 19
fraîcheur du coup les imitateurs vont
petit à petit reprendre le tube parce
que quand tu mets des tricheurs entre
eux eh ben ils gagnent plus rien parce
que quand tu triches compte un tricheur
tu gagne rien et c'est ce qui se passe
entre ses intérêts sort donc on revient
sur le 4e tournoi et on peut voir que
les six meilleurs scores sont les
imitateurs donc tu va dégager 5
tricheurs parmi les 19 qui sont les cinq
pires joueurs et tu va dupliquer les
cinq meilleurs qui sont des imitateurs
les tricheurs deviennent victimes de
leur propre succès il exploite la
naïveté de ceux qui opèrent tout le
temps mais une fois qu'il ya plus du
tout des gens pour coopérer et ben ils
font face aux imitateurs qui sont des
gens bons mais pas naïf on continue il
se passe la même chose parce que les
imitateurs entre gagne mme ashton alors
que les tricheurs quand ils trichent
contre un imitateur bas ça marche pas et
de quoi finir avec une population
d'imitateur les tricheurs ou gagner sur
une courte période mais son
exploitabilité a mené à sa chute
au revoir richer bilan il semble que les
mathématiques de la théorie des jeux
nous raconte quelque chose la
philosophie de l'imitateur correspond
donc au fait aux autres ce que vous
voudriez qu'ils vous fassent c'est bon
toutefois au ya khouya en pâtit
si la stratégie de l'imitateur dans ce
jeu qu'on a répété plusieurs fois et si
puissante tellement puissante qu'elle a
amené les soldats dans les tranchées de
la première guerre mondiale
indépendamment mettre au point la même
stratégie à savoir la stratégie du vivre
et laisser vivre
on en est arrivé à un point où les gens
n'ont plus confiance et ne sont plus
dignes de confiance
qu'est ce qui a causé cette épidémie de
membres de confiance on va donc répéter
le même jeu mais cette fois il ya
vingt-trois personnes qui coopèrent tout
le temps un tricheur et un imitateur
start
donc on vient de voir que en faisant dix
rounds par match et est plus que
l'imitateur mais quand tu changes le
nombre de rounds ça change tout si tu
mets karun par exemple logiquement le
tricheur haletant de berne et
l'imitateur parce que l'imitateur n'a
pas le temps d'imiter le mec qui
trichent voilà et comme tu viens de
découvrir par toi même
- iliad interactions répétés entre des
individus plus la méfiance va se
répandre génial mais il existe une autre
manière de susciter la méfiance
habituellement l'imitateur gagne mais
changeons le gain généré quand deux
personnes coopèrent habituellement ils
gagnent chacun deux pièces faisant en
sorte qu'ils n'en gagnent qu'une on va
mettre en plus un du coup eh ben les
tricheurs se répandent énormément la
même chose se produit avec une
récompense gagnant-gagnant inférieur
donc quand les deux coopère le tricheur
prend le relais est triste c'est à dire
que même si a que des gens qui coopèrent
y gagner au final moins de pièces qu'un
tricheur
la théorie des jeux à deux idées
puissante à ce sujet le jeu du zéro
somme c'est la conviction
malheureusement commune qu'un gain pour
nous doit venir à la perte d'un autre et
vice versa c'est vrai souvent quand tu
gagnes un truc tu dis que l'autre bas il
a perdu quelque chose et le jeu à somme
nulle c'est quand les gens font un gros
effort pour créer un jeu gagnant gagnant
où au moins d'éviter le père tu perds tu
sens le jeu à somme nulle la confiance
ne peut évoluer bien évidemment pas ce
que tu dis que si tu gagnes un truc
c'est que l'hôte a perdu quelque chose
dont tu vas devenir tricheurs finalement
c'est triste aussi cool qu'avec
l'imitateur il ya une énorme faiblesse
fatale que je n'ai pas encore mentionné
pour comprendre le problème disons que
deux imitateurs joue les uns contre les
autres étant des bons joueurs ton
premier move hâte de coopérer bien
évidemment à partir de là normalement
ils vont juste chacun coopérer à chaque
fois mais que faire si en essayant de
russie pro qu'est la bonté pasqua
oh non les erreurs la mauvaise
communication et la mauvaise
interprétation sont des accidents qui
arrivent tout le temps dans la vraie vie
mais si l'autre personne ne pense pas
que c'était un accident alors il va
tricher la fois d'après au nom pour la
deuxième fois cette fois c'est l'autre
qui est déçu et vu que c'est lui aussi
un imitateur et ben il va tricher et
donc les deux vont chacun tricher à
l'infini voilà il a suffi d'un élément
pour que pour ce sadique tous les amis
petit ellipses on a refait l'expérience
avec des nouveaux caractères c'est assez
intéressant mais ça dépend beaucoup tôt
expliqué alors qu'au final le
raisonnement est le même la théorie des
jeux nous a montré trois choses dont
nous avons besoin pour l'évolution de la
confiance premièrement des interactions
répétés entre les mêmes individus
deuxièmement il faut jouer un jeu sans
somme nulle donc un jeu gagnant gagnant
vous n'avez pas un jeu où il ya un
gagnant et un perdant
troisièmement il faut qu'ils aient le
moins d'erreurs de communication
possibles entre les deux parce que si le
niveau d' erreur de communication est
trop haut alors le niveau de confiance
va chuter mais quand il ya peu d'erreurs
de communication alors les gens arrivent
à pardonner et y'a pas de soucis inutile
de rappeler que dans le monde dans
lequel on vit à bien plus de facteurs
que ça comme la réputation le partage
des valeurs les contrats les marqueurs
culturels bla bla bla bla maintenant la
conclusion finale ce qu'il faut retenir
de tout ça ce que le jeu est défini ce
que les joueurs vont faire le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement que les
gens perdent confiance c'est que notre
environnement agit contre l'évolution de
la confiance ça peut sembler cynique ou
naïfs que nous sommes simplement des
produits de notre environnement et comme
la théorie des jeux nous rappelle nous
sommes l'environnement de chacun à court
terme le jeu défini les joueurs mais à
long terme ce sont nous les joueurs qui
définissent le jeu what else
donc on commence à être ripoux le jeu
devient ripoux et on est ripoux et le
jeu devient ripoux et ça s'arrête plus
donc faites ce que vous pouvez faire
pour créer les conditions nécessaires à
l'évolution de la confiance
établissez des relations trouver des
victoires communiquer clairement
peut-être nous pouvons arrêter de tirer
les uns contre les autres sortir de nos
propres tranché traverser nos madeleine
pour venir ensemble et apprendre à vivre
et à laisser vivre
oui j'ai beaucoup aimé c'était facile
pour moi comme vidéo j'avais juste à
lire ce que ce mec qui lui d'un génie a
écrit mais tu comprends mieux pourquoi
on en est arrivé là pourquoi ça
s'arrange pas et comment on peut faire
un autre échelle pour que petit à petit
on rendre les gens autour de nous meyer
qui rendent les gens autour de meyer qui
rend les gens autour de meilleurs et ce
qui fait qu'on va redéfinir les règles
du jeu et le jeu sera plus gagnant
gagnant et nous seront de meilleure
personne c'est beau j'ai aimé
baptiste pas à mêler de ça vous a plu un
peu de sociologie comme ça ça fait
maintenant pourquoi les gens ne se font
plus confiance voire pardo puisqu'on des
proches voilà tout ça vidal à tous
prochaine vidéo qui sera drôle vous en
faites pas là j'avais vraiment envie de
faire un petit peu de sociologie ça
faisait longtemps et j'ai pu kim
apparaître ce truc là mais ça va tout de
suite intéressé je suis content d'avoir
osé faire cette vidéo vous des bateaux
prochaine
[Musique]